today's one minute Monday is get
personal so many people are so afraid of
sharing anything personal about
themselves because you're worried that
you're going to get judged you're
worried what the other people are going
to think about you when you show a
little bit more of yourself but this is
so important because if you are all
business you're not going to get any
business you have to be able to connect
with people on a personal level and that
starts with you sharing something
personal about yourself so here's a
quick example yesterday I was cleaning
my son's room with my son my 5-year-old
son and we came across some stickers
from the movie Planes and he said Daddy
Daddy I want to give you one of my
stickers can I put it on your hand and
so I said yes and so he did and I'm
wearing it here so then last night I was
cleaning up I had uh I had to meet some
customers and I was washing up and
washing my hands and I saw the sticker I
was about to take it off and I thought
you know what I'm going to keep it on
because it's personal it shows part of
who I am and what my day-to-day life is
all about and it was awesome awesome
people notice a sticker they ask
questions they wanted to know where it
came from I told them about my son it
was a great opening they talked about
their kids we talked about the funds of
Parenthood and sometimes the not so
funds of Parenthood and it allowed me to
connect with them in such a quick easy
open way and then we got the business
and that's going to lead to more
business because the more you can
connect with that person the more you
can make them feel you and get to know
you the less it seems just like a
business transaction the more likely
they're going to want to sign up with
you and stay with you for the long term
tell their friends about you and have an
awesome business relationship so get
personal tell them about yourself wear a
shirt that means something to you wear a
sticker if your son gives it to you do
something this week to get personal with
your clients it'll help your business
grow
believe if you want the real Goods I
share my best advice for entrepreneurs
every week in my newsletter click the
link below to check it out it's free hi
hi I'm Jason J rise fona of Rise
online.com and I want to say Evan
Carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun inspiring and it's the only
newsletter I prioritize and look forward
to period